Escribe de nuevo la ecuación "6x" cuadrada
más 3 es igual a "2x" menos 6
en su forma estándar e identifica "a", "b" y "c".
Y bueno, esencialmente tener una ecuación
cuadrática de la forma estándar es tener
algo de la forma "x" cuadrada más "bx" más
"c" esto igualado a 0.
Perfecto y para esto, lo que tenemos que hacer
es pasar todo del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
para que esté igualado a 0 y además ordenar
los términos de la siguiente manera,
tener primero los términos que tienen que ver con
"x" cuadrada, después los términos que tienen
que ver con la "x" normal y después los términos
que tienen que ver con la constante.
Así que para esto déjame primero escribir
otra vez de nuevo esta ecuación,
me va a quedar "6x" cuadrada más 3, esto es igual
a "2x" menos 6, así que bueno para pasar
a la forma estándar lo que hay que hacer
es pasar estos términos que están del lado
derecho, al lado izquierdo.
Muy bien, lo primero que voy a hacer es quitar
este "2x" del lado derecho de la ecuación
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es agregar
"-2x" de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y entonces, ¿qué me va a quedar?
"6x" cuadrada y ojo, voy a poner primero "6x"
cuadrada para ir acomodando estos términos,
de tal manera que los tenga de forma decreciente,
es decir, primero los términos que tienen
que ver con "x" cuadrada, después los términos
que tienen que ver con "x"
y después los términos que tienen que
ver con la constante,
"6x" cuadrada menos "2x" más 3 esto es igual...
y bueno, del lado derecho "2x" menos "2x"
se cancelan y solamente me queda -6 y bueno,
ahora también voy a pasar el -6 del otro
lado de la ecuación y para esto lo que voy
a hacer es cambiar de color y sumar 6 de ambos
lados de la ecuación.
De este lado voy a sumar 6 y de este lado
también voy a sumar 6.
¿Entonces qué me va a quedar?
"6x" cuadrada menos "2x", 3 más 6 me dan
9 y del otro lado, -6 más 6 se cancelan
y simple y sencillamente me queda 0.
Y ahora la pregunta es, ya estamos en la forma
estándar y date cuenta que sí, ya tenemos
esto igualado a 0 y además tenemos los términos
acomodados de forma decreciente,
según las potencias de "x", es decir, primero tenemos
lo que tiene que ver con "x" cuadrada, después
lo que tiene que ver con la "x" a la primera potencia y después lo que tiene que ver con la constante.
Y entonces ya lo tenemos de la forma "ax" cuadrada
más "bx" más "c" igual a 0.
Perfecto, porque entonces ya estamos en forma
estándar, entonces lo único que nos falta
es encontrar "a", "b" y "c".
"a" es el coeficiente que está al lado de
la "x" cuadrada, por lo tanto, en este caso
"a" vale 6, "b" es el coeficiente que está
al lado de la "x", pero aquí está la clave,
"b" en este caso vale -2,
aquí dice más "bx" pero como el coeficiente que está al
lado de la "x" es un número negativo
hay que tomar todo este coeficiente con todo y signo.
Entonces vamos a escribir que "b" vale -2.
Y por último, vamos a ver cuanto vale el
valor de "c", "c" es el valor constante que
tenemos en la ecuación que en este caso vale 9,
por lo tanto, puedo decir que "c" vale 9.